Thank You senator Lautenberg for your
inspirational words and your dedication
to the country as someone with a
graduate business degree it's rather
humbling to understand what can be done
with an undergraduate business degree
and of just for a few more moments
Monica I'd like to thank you and the
assembly planning committee for the
wonderful panel and program this evening
and for the program that we are all
looking forward to tomorrow I'd also
like to thank the staff from Columbia's
alumni and Development Office Susan
Fagan and Donna McPhee and Jose and
Jesse and Aileen and Michael and all the
other professionals from alumni affairs
that work so hard to make programs like
this and programs throughout the entire
year successful for those of us who are
alums it's wonderful to see so many
alumni this evening representing so many
of Columbia's schools and their various
affinity groups many of you I know from
prior columbia alumni events over the
years some of you I recognize at least
from having seen you at other events and
I was very pleased to meet some of you
and look forward to meeting even more in
the reception across the hall in a few
minutes on your way there I would
encourage you to look at and take some
of the materials that are out on the
table having to do with Columbia
especially Columbia's alumni programs
there's an awful lot going on under the
auspices of the CAA nearly all schools
in fact I think with the exception of
one are now represented on the CIA board
there is increased concrete effective
collaboration across schools with
respect to their alumni efforts and
their alumni communities a big emphasis
on networking and career services
is for alumni a lot of improvement yet
to come but a lot of work already done
an increased number of CAA events I
actually get a little bit dizzy on the
website now trying to focus on what it
is that I might attend but I would
encourage you you will find something of
interest there academically
intellectually socially in the arts it's
really a very very fine resource for us
and the opening earlier this year of the
new columbia alumni center a place for
us to go when we visit campus on a
hundred and thirteenth street almost to
riverside avenue a very handsome
welcoming convenient place for alumni to
visit when they returned to Columbia as
we end this program I would like to tell
you just a little bit about the columbia
alumni arts league I guess it's called
Cal and there's a program and exhibits
across the hall as part of our reception
Matthew niederhauser 05 the college was
one of our most intrepid and successful
young alumni artists whose photographs
have appeared in such publications as
The New Yorker Time magazine The
Washington Post The Economist and the
Guardian weekly amongst others that put
together a preview exhibition which
captures the burgeoning music
underground in Beijing now this is an
eclectic presentation which is currently
led by two other columbia alumni michael
pettis and charles saliba for more
information about this exhibition and
its related events please turn to the
handouts at your seats and now I invite
you to join all of us across the hall
for the reception and thank you very
much for coming
you